bom valeu frança onde vocês acham que
conhece conhece trazendo frança foi
convidado aqui porque eu que já sofre de
alguns organizadores silva trabalho é
assistir perdeu um pouco de seu tempo
mas sim na internet e achar que eu possa
servir de exemplo para cada um tem uma
coisa que me esforço muito para ser um
bom exemplo né
caso não seja um exemplo problemas eu
sou mal pra não se brinca mas vou fazer
de tudo para ser um bom e seu lado bom
anunciou o instituto tecnológico de
aeronáutica a gente tem uma academia em
cada dia mais pessoas estão aderindo a
esse estilo de vida saudável a esse
estímulo a trabalhar principalmente
quando também corpo
aliás uma coisa está ligada a outra
por coincidência nesse tempo eu estava
trabalhando num projeto que fala
exatamente disso a diferença que faz uma
pessoa que acredita na mudança de uma
pessoa que está lá porque alguém falou
toda mudança seja um fico ou seja era
qualquer coisa qualquer área da sua vida
ela começa na cabeça
ela começa a tv então eu quero ter uma
vida não definido eu quero ganhar uns em
direito de bissau é preciso lançar mão à
coxa com a omd que isso começa nisso
começa na cabeça a primeira coisa que se
deve fazer é acreditar que você consegue
isso seja por um impulso provavelmente
você vai falar meu deus não saber se era
tão difícil e vai parar no meio do
caminho
agora eu realmente espero que você
consegue assim como qualquer outra coisa
na sua vida você vai passar pela
primeira dificuldade pela segunda
dificuldade pela terceira dificuldade e
vai conseguir o que você quer seja lá se
informar um grande professor se um
grande mestre na área do que você
trabalhava o que você quiser trabalhar
um dia na sua vida ou seja a chave para
que a cinturinha fina que eu sempre quis
sempre quis ter a região
outras pessoas que assistem como eu
trabalho na internet ela também falou a
gente quer montar um produto pra você
a gente quer montar um produto
utilizando tudo conversado que é capaz
de fazer as pessoas mudarem o corpo
quem você acha que pode fazer pra gente
aí eu falei pra eles olha dica vá mudar
o corpo exercício agassi assim na caixa
daquele jeito mas a barra até o peito
levanta bar e se já tem tanto por aí eu
achei uma coisa que falta às pessoas
aprender e entender em verdade que você
precisa acreditar no que você está
fazendo
interessa-nos situação não interessa
seja um trabalho que se queixa de não
estar satisfeito tem que usar de tudo
você tem de tudo você pode ter a sua
capacidade de acreditar e de se mexer
para conseguir o que você quer eu queria
passar isso e não comecei a escrever
fusão com a simlis chegaram até mim
achei que ia então programa de
musculação corrida fácil chegar lá a
segunda feira fazer 37 suprirão quatro
séries de bens e desconcentrado 15
minutos externa
isso é praticamente um óbvio para quem
quer começar uma vida ativa na atividade
física
eu queria mostrar que a pessoa tem que
ter artifícios para continuar começar é
para as outras pessoas já faz um mês e
acabei falando
muito mais começa a procurar dentro de
si mesmo todas as desculpas socializar e
tentei com ice eu estou com um problema
no joelho nem sabem do méxico está com
um problema no joelho está com um
problema no ombro
ai eu tenho que treinar vai mas livros
sexta-feira não vou poder tomar aquela
cerveja editar o que você quer
o que você quer de verdade você tem que
pegar o que você quer de verdade ser
fiel a você mesmo
então a primeira coisa que você tem que
fazer para ter sucesso seja lá o que for
introduzido na sua ação inclusive
qualquer atividade física inclusive em
qualquer área da sua vida a primeira
coisa que tem que acreditar que você
consegue visualizar você já conseguido
que você quer
a gente se vê no futuro já uma pessoa de
sucesso que já passou por todas as fases
que você precisava passar já sofreu tudo
que você precisava sofrer metade e
conseguiu uma coisa que nunca vai ficar
só sei que vai chegar só está
conseguindo você quer que você vai
querer mais abonados é ótimo
isso é muito bom frank está feliz se ele
está orgulhoso sempre de tudo o que você
passou de todos os passos concedeu
orgulhoso sempre mais satisfeito e nunca
como descobrir qual é o melhor caminho
pra isso é fácil de eventos um sucesso
deixa pistas
então você pega em dezembro por exemplo
eu era moleque e ia ser forte meu deus
eu quero ter músculos o que é mais pra
isso
a primeira coisa que você é mágica a
galera busca pela pílula que vai fazer
você perder 20 quilos a pessoa demora
anos para importar e quer mais recente
cinco dias
isso é normal todo mundo busca à tarde
em que sofri mais gente
o sucesso dói o sucesso e dolorida aqui
aquele terminou bem ninguém sem dor sem
danny 70 por aesão paulo - o que
significa casinha de musculação dói mais
é doente eu vou crescer não o sucesso do
o sucesso você tem de estudar uma pessoa
sucedida no seu trabalho não tem de
trabalhar todo dia 8 10 do sucesso da
anterior que não vai pra mim isso é
fácil é o que queria fazer essa queria
têm casas em palmas o fato de uma sala
de tv não vai estar conseguindo você
quer sem saber que o sucesso é dolorido
isso na sua ação nesse no trabalho e
isso seja aonde quer que seja você tem
que acreditar
você não pode ficar procurando desculpas
que desculpas a gente tem de sobra todo
mundo tem todo mundo não tem tempo pra
comer direito
todo mundo não tem tempo de ir à
academia todo mundo tem medo às vezes a
pessoa não está satisfeita com chinesa
esquece do maior poder de semana é o
poder da escolha a pessoa não está
satisfeita com o trabalho mas eu não vou
mudar
eu não sei como é que vai ser se eu
mudar se eu sair daqui eu não sei como é
que vai ser
esse é o medo o maior poder no ser
humano é muito muito importante já que
sentem de verdade você vai sentir outra
pessoa
o maior poder do ser humano é o poder da
escolha
você pode escolher não tenha medo de
escolher hoje não está satisfeita e sua
sócia anos a vida insatisfeitos com a
relação está feliz com a pessoa que está
do lado mas não quer mudar porque têm
medo aí não usa na verdade usa o poder
da escolha
simples a maneira mais confortável que
eu tô aqui não tinha aqui em pedra
chance de ser uma pessoa feliz
a pessoa tem satisfeito com o trabalho e
não quero dar a pessoa tem sempre compro
por exemplo quero sair daqui agora o que
impede ainda a vontade da cabocha dessa
fala que ninguém pode sair daqui pra
cancun
aí o dinheiro vai até nem falou que é
fácil ser campeão é difícil é aí quem
falou que era fácil que se fosse fácil
qual seria a graça é fácil sair daqui
nem da sua casa é muito ruim é não é tão
simples assim mais um sentindo é esse o
que te impede de sair da onde você está
agora na sua relação não citava o seu
trabalho não está agora aqui agora ir a
qualquer lugar nesse tal incrível é o
sensacional poder do ser humano única
coisa que você precisa fazer é acreditar
em você mesmo porque o que mais tem a
gente vai falar que você não consegue
andar que não é possível acreditar eu já
passei por tantos problemas junto com a
minha família experiência própria eu meu
irmão e eu via que a maior diferença
como a gente viu sair de casa ea maior
diferença
enfim eu e as pessoas que estavam ali
comigo passando pelo mesmo problema é
que eu acreditava que era possível sair
eu acreditava que era possível melhorar
eu falava gente se ele consegue porque
que eu consigo dinheiro de uma maneira
mais fácil que tem uma vantagem sobre
isso significa conseguir atingir o que
ele fazia fazia deu certo porque era com
ele que é ser um dia o maior até hoje
mas eu sei que aquele espaço físico
eu não tinha um real meu deus deixa
estudar pessoas de sucesso
a gente estudava um comportamento do
semana achava muito legal e entender o
comportamento do ser humano
comecei a estudar e rock por exemplo
alguém conhece de uma foto dele
assim eu tenho de responder sim muito
porque eu havia falado não pode ser
parecia mágica cada coisa que eu ia
falar isso aqui é sensacional esse cara
é um gênio e como foi a dele saiu do
buraco de chegou ele é um bilionário que
dá palestras motivacionais na escala o
exemplo e ele saiu do nada e chegaram
chegar onde ele está hoje
sendo um bom exemplo sem passar por cima
de ninguém nem fazendo o que você tem
que fazer se você quer emagrecer o que
você tem que fazer se você quer um
trunfo de peso o que você tem que fazer
se quiser ganhar dinheiro que acreditar
em si mesmo seguir com os exemplos e à
luta da catata papa porque dá a cara a
tapa coisa que a pessoa quer emagrecer
ah eu quero emagrecer ouvi falar que tem
que correr pela concessionária mas eu
tenho que manter a freqüência cardíaca
70% o tempo correr 40 minutos é legal
comel corre-corre sai correndo e vai
acontecer em duas horas e vai manter 70%
e 70 batimentos cardíacos por minuto
você precisa com os oito trafford e
limpa dentro do meu
as pessoas procuram o jeito perfeito de
fazer tudo e o sucesso super pessoa de
sucesso
são pessoas que passaram milhares de
vezes e não desistir nunca
são pessoas que caiu 8 levantar uma
pedra ou 10 levantar 11
essas pessoas saíram do ponto que elas
estavam e não estavam satisfeitas e
chegar a um ponto que elas estão longe
de são felizes só que não estão fáceis e
mais é bom demais é uma coisa que a
gente tem que querer sempre seja lá onde
for
as pessoas me conhecem para uma situação
de tudo o que eu aprendi na musculação
porque dói
na consolação dói é proibido olha eu
tenho 22
então pra crescer dói eu apliquei todos
aqueles que aprendizado sobre o que é
importante o quanto a gente cresce
sofrendo passando querendo ser sempre
melhor o que isso em toda a minha vida
por isso que quando chega pra mim posso
ganhar a gente quer que se faça um
projeto sobre uma situação que ele
aprendeu o projeto de mente eroica que
eu falei isso tem alguma coisa se tem
alguém que vai ter que salvar que vai
fazer você crescer vai fazer você ser
melhor seja lá onde for e se alguém é
você mesmo a sua cabeça então o seu
herói mora dentro da silva mente a hora
que você descobrir ele começa a
acreditar mais em você você saiba aonde
você quiser você saiba que você tá me
chega aonde você quiser chegar a minha
dica eu vim aqui até hoje para falar que
seja assim foi uma situação seja lá se
foi o teatro seja lá segundo seu
escritório
acredite em você a minha dica acredite
mais em você que pode chegar aonde você
quiser não só commodities deu o sucesso
do livro com ela esse legado dele